I've spent the last dozen years thinking
about what I consider to be one of the
fundamental challenges of leadership and
that is the challenge to notice critical
information in your environment there
are so many interesting stories of the
new millennium of situations where there
were people who behaved inappropriately
and they get an awful lot of attention
in the headlines from Madoff to JP
Morgan's recent problems to Enron and
across the hundreds of scandals there
are often some bad people doing some bad
things my focus is not on those
individuals but the fact that in each of
those cases there are so many other
people who should have noticed something
was wrong
and they didn't warren bennis the
leadership scholar talked about one of
the characteristics of an excellent
leader as somebody who is a first-class
noticer and my book on the power of
noticing is really an attempt to help
MBA students executives to become
first-class notices so that they can be
aware of problems challenges and
opportunities that would allow them to
be more effective the truth is I don't
consider myself to be a particularly
effective noticer I've been working on
in a lot in the last dozen years but I
always took pride in my ability to focus
as opposed to my ability to notice and
some of us who focus very very
effectively might want to think about
the question of whether they can develop
the skills of noticing to go along with
her skills of focusing a number of years
ago I had an opportunity to notice and I
failed to do so and it's been an
obsession with me ever since on March
10th 2005 I was hired by the US
Department of Justice and a landmark
case that they were fighting against the
tobacco industry I was hired as a remedy
witness that is I was hired to provide
recommendations to the court about what
the penalty would be if in fact the
Department of Justice succeeded in its
trial against the tobacco industry I had
spent a couple hundred hours working for
the Department of Justice
including submitting my written direct
testimony which had been submitted to
the court I was scheduled to be on the
stand on May 4th where the tobacco
industry attorneys would be asking a
series of questions on April 30th a
number of days before my May 4th
testimony I was in Washington DC to be
to meet with Department of Justice
attorneys to prepare for my time on the
stand when the day started the
Department of Justice attorney that I
had been working with said to me
professor bazerman this occurred long
after he had learned to call me max he
said professor bazerman the Department
of Justice requests that you amend your
testimony to note that the testimony
would not be relevant if any of the
following four conditions existed he
then read to me for legal conditions
that I didn't understand when he was
done talking I said to him why would you
ask me to amend my testimony when you
know that I didn't understand
what you just said to me and his
response was because if you don't agree
there's a significant chance that senior
leadership in the Department of Justice
will remove you from the case before you
are on the stand on May 4th to which I
said okay I don't agree to those changes
and his response was good let's continue
with your preparation I was jarred by
the fact that something very strange had
occurred but I was overwhelmed in life I
was trying to help this case and I
didn't quite know what had occurred but
to this day I'm critical of the fact
that they took no action I did appear on
trial on May 4th and the trial ended in
early June but on June 17th I woke up in
a hotel room in London I was working
with another client at the time and I
woke up early at 5:00 a.m. and I opened
up the New York Times web web edition
and I read a story about Matt Myers the
president of tobacco-free kids who had
come forward to the media with evidence
about how Robert McCollum the number-two
official in the Department of Justice
was involved in attempting to get him to
change his testimony and I then read
basically the same account that I had
experienced back on April 30th Matt
Myers
had the insight to know that he should
do something with this information about
what had occurred in terms of the
attempt to tamper with his testimony and
at that point it was straightforward to
come forward to the media to speak to
congressional representatives about what
happened and my own role received media
attention as well but to this day I'm
still struck by the fact that I didn't
come forward on April 30th when in the
back of my mind I knew something had
occurred
the reason I tell you this story is
because I think a lot of our failure to
notice happens when we're busy it
happens when we don't know exactly
what's happening but I think it's our
job as executives as leaders as
professionals to act when we're pretty
sure that there's something wrong it's
our job to notice and to not simply be
passive when we can't quite figure out
the evidence it's our job to take steps
to figure out what's going on and to act
on on critical information
you